damn mrs. hunt you have the medicine
that can make me feel much better and
not have to spend so much time in
hospital please say it to my country
it was fantastis a fibrosis I know you
would understand I know the price of for
company Thank You Lewis Walker I used I
Louis Walker is a boy on a mission not
content with writing a letter to the
prime minister he's now written directly
to the manufacturer of the drug he needs
drug why is that so I would spend so
much time in hospital I don't like it
cuz I have to miss school and I'm
missing my friends every morning Louis
does his breathing and physio exercises
his cystic fibrosis is regressive and
will get worse but with a drug called or
cami his symptoms will continue to stay
manageable cystic fibrosis is caused by
a faulty gene that disrupts the movement
of soap and water in the body cells
they're all around 10,000 people who
suffer from CS in the UK it's thought
almost half words benefit from the drug
but at 100,000 pounds per person per
year the NHS says it can't afford it
after a long-running negotiation it's
final offer to the u.s. manufacturer is
half a billion pounds over five years
that's around a quarter of what's being
asked for lewis's mum the company and
the NHS need to work harder certainly
cystic fibrosis can have a near normal
future with these medicines they're
amazing so the NHS is undervaluing them
they do need to up their offer but they
won't be able to reach vertexes asking
price so that's why I'm thought it was
really important that we appeal to their
take in a statement the drugs company
said we share the frustration of Louis
and the thousands of people in England
with cystic fibrosis who are still
waiting for access to our medicines we
again urge NHS chief executive Simon
Stephens to come to the table so
patients in England don't have to wait
any longer
Louis and his mum hope their action will
force a change in the meantime
eight year old campaigner has definitely
earned himself an ice cream
Joe tidy Sky News